la crisis migratoria en belarús continúa
y su presidente alexander lukashenko
parece estar convencido de que aumentará
si no se encuentra una pronta solución
el mandatario acusó de la situación a la
unión europea y afirmó en una visita a
un centro de migrantes que no los
repartirá y que será difícil contenerlos
en la frontera
y no oprimir 'hemos a esta gente no lo
haremos y si ellos quieren que los
atrape mos en la frontera y los
detengamos tampoco lo haremos ellos no
quieren resolver este problema
no les repatriaremos les pediremos a los
que puedan que se vayan como pueden ver
estoy cumpliendo con mi deber
este mensaje busca poner presión sobre
bruselas que durante semanas lleva
conteniendo a miles de personas
provenientes de medio oriente y áfrica
estos migrantes han tenido que soportar
situaciones límite de frío y hambre las
filas en busca de alimentos se
multiplican al igual que la
desesperación por la incertidumbre algo
que ha hecho que muchos hayan decidido
volver a sus hogares en vuelos de
repatriación
y no habían regresado más de 170
personas y estamos muy agradecidos por
llegar a casa porque la humanidad y la
justicia que la gente dice sobre europa
está lejos de la realidad no es cierto
en absoluto nos han golpeado brutalmente
letras dao vélez dan la cuestión
migratoria ha acentuado las tensiones
entre la unión europea y belarús ya que
desde el bloque comunitario afirman que
estas personas fueron atraídos por mins
para desestabilizar a bruselas